The learning goals, outcomes, and
assessments of this course all mention
the idea of contributing to
the field of educational technology.
So it's really important that we ask,
what is educational technology?
Is educational technology
only the use of technology
in the context of learning?
As far as we're concerned, no.
For us, educational technologie
is any place for education and
technology intersect.
Even if it occurs far away from
the actual learning process.
So, for example, we could use technology
to help the admissions process,
to identify what students
are more likely to succeed.
We can use technology to
facilitate registration.
In fact, we already do, but
we can use it to make it better.
We could use technology
to help load balance or
anticipate what classes are going
to draw more students so
we can allocate our resources
more intelligently.
We could use technology to facilitate
collaboration at a distance,
to help students work on group projects
together even when they're not located
in the same place.
And there's also a big field that's not
the education using technology, but
it's the education of technology.
Teaching students to use technology or
to program or things like that.
So there are a lot of
places where education and
technology intersect that aren't right
there in the context of learning.
And as far as we're concerned,
they all fall under the umbrella
of educational technology.